okay so alvin what are you doing here
i'm here because you're gonna be on the
season finale of the burger show
let's get it
the season finale of the burger show is
here
and it wouldn't be a party without my
friend chef joshua weissman
his viral cooking series but better has
turned him into an internet sensation
today we're to settle it once and for
all what makes a perfect burger meal
beyond the bun and patty let's do this
it's the burger show baby burger how are
you feeling dude i feel great
you're a burger nerd i'm a burger nerd
this is the perfect time to
actually explore what we feel is the
best
burger meal to you what's the perfect
burger meal so you need just two simple
things
burger fries obviously fries we'll talk
about fries later because that's a big
conversation and then
a nice paloma right next to you icy
cold paloma it's citrusy it's sweet
you've got the mezcal in there so it's a
little smoky some tequila maybe you feel
a little loosey-goosey you're not
completely blasted because you want to
taste the burger
but just relaxed i agree bring you back
when it comes to my side you know it's
all about meat cheese and bun
the ingredients the simplicity it's like
a cheese pizza so
i can't wait to see what you come up
with so let's get started
so my guy
sorry you're looking at me with those
loving eyes he's my guy
what are we doing today what are you
making okay well we're making a burger
dude yeah i mean like how
what how are you doing it's not the
quesadilla show okay so
i think when we make this burger it's
just more so looking at each element and
trying to bring it to the highest level
that it can be okay
and more specifically technique
in every step every step every step i
think we should start with
the cornerstone or well the middle stone
because it's in the middle
between two buns is the beef obviously
you can buy pre-ground but i think it's
a whole lot better if you grind it
yourself
being able to control the fat ratio
exactly how you want it
that's that's one that's key so you have
to get
really good quality meats from amboy
quality meats
that's a plug right there i don't have a
butcher so you get it from him so we
have
short rib here this is boneless
obviously and then we have chuck roast
here
this is going to bring a lot more fat so
we're going to mix that in
but i like to cut it into strips all
right
you can do that with it or you can just
feed it to the grinder whatever you want
to do with it
boom and it comes out the other end just
like that it's like a little time
machine
i think it looks beautiful we're going
to make a burger out of this no you
gotta gotta emulsify the fat with the
meat and mix it a little bit you're not
putting egg in it not putting eggs
you're not playing bread crumbs it's
like when you make a good meatball
you know how it's like springy yeah
that's usually what i go for
so you see this is important because
when you start cooking that
yeah you don't want it to fall apart
right next step i think we should make
our sauce let's make some sauce we've
got a caramelized onion that takes so
dang long
these are sweet onions right you know
you want you can use any onion
technically to caramelize but why not
use one that has a lot of sugar we're
gonna
julienne it that's what we'll do in this
case we're gonna cut them a little
thinner
just so that they cook a little faster
so don't do
exactly what i'm doing i'm impressed i
just thought it would be a little faster
i'm gonna chop the [ __ ] out of this oh
it's done we have butter
okay onions going in to the butter so i
think you should have caramelized onion
it should absolutely have pickles in it
and it
you need to have that classic mayo
ketchup combo oh you can't skip that
i got this um ancient ancient kosher the
salt is like 4
billion years old but alvin this one
this one's for you
socially distance uh
there she is he just did the the social
distance josie dough
typically i would make my own mayo so
anyone's watching this for my channel is
probably going to leave a comment like
oh my god joshua uses a mayo he's
falling apart like he's depressed like
somebody help him
i'm okay guys all right thank you so
mayo's gonna go in
oh look at that this this is emulsified
right here
burger show burger show
ketchup i'll probably go maybe one to
two
roughly something like that we've got
our worcestershire
dishes worse to sure sauce yeah i always
struggled
pronouncing this a couple good drops of
that black pepper this is
pre-ground don't ever do this what is
this garbage what is this
so normally we do fresh cracked black
pepper pencil shavings
so i'm gonna mix all this together i
mean i think we could just cut veg while
we're waiting is that cool yeah let's do
it
cool let's let's set it up so i'm down
here
let's talk about the thickness of a
tomato go thin
or go home i think right about
yeah i think this is my optimum
thickness right here you kind of see
through it i like it
you want it that thin oh
okay now at home try it i forgot about
pickles
when you use pickles in a sauce right
yeah that's right i opened the pickle
jar all right strong
yeah i saw that okay so i think we'll
dice these
smaller than bite size like little baby
teeth is that a weird
size a little bit of weird what is wrong
with you all right so then we're good
to add these pickles no mustard in there
sometimes i add mustard sometimes they
don't but because you're here if you
have mustard i'll add it
i have mustard what kind of mustard is
it as the ad goes
poop on me yeah we'll do that much
you can grab that and let me know what
you think oh yeah
look at that we're ready to add these
guys they look beautiful
steamin and gleamin and then we're gonna
add them straight
to our burger sauce i think this is a
burger it looks like a beautiful
big batch of burger sauce butt lettuce
butt lettuce that's what that's the only
reason i use butter lettuce because i
can say that
you've become famous for your butt kinda
oh my god i know
how does it feel to be a butt meme not
good
show your butt a couple times on the
internet i just wouldn't recommend it if
you're thinking about it just don't do
it
this lettuce to me is a good mix of
crunch soft
okay you still have like the texture of
the leaf in between before i jump on
this can you griddle one
sliced onion for me sure are we looking
like brulee texture or
brulee buns these are beautiful who who
made these
yeah that's actually from my baker bread
bar what
uh that's actually the bun that we use
at egg [ __ ]
look at the shine on these dudes this is
a hallmark perfect bun right yeah when
you have one of the most instagram
restaurants in the world you have to
have good puns
whoa damn that was a flex all right bye
i like walk away with a limp like oh
[ __ ]
my reasoning behind this bun why i
prefer sort of a brioche or a
or a milk bread is it's a little bit
more rich
but more specifically the texture the
way it is when it's toasted
it gets super crispy on the outside
because of the extra fat
but it's also ultra ultra light and
fluffy on the inside
kind of tastes like a donut and that
that box look at that
laser oh the smell i got you i got one i
think you're ready to hit it with butter
i got it i got it oh thank you
alvin teamwork everybody team work he
slapped right against his hand
oof every base just slapping we've got
some cave aged gruyere
just saying oh by the way for people
cheddar gruyere refined a little more
normal a little more relaxed
i think i'll do a 50 50 of both so
before we assemble we're going to toast
our buns
burger time burger time we got our plump
boy here look at that
all right you roll into balls pre-press
a little bit get an idea of how big your
balls should be
you know one ball is always a little
bigger than that right ball goes in
oh sizzle good news okay we're just
gonna press it down
i'm gonna hit it with some salt we're
just gonna sear this
two minutes three minutes let's see
let's see
look at that so at this point i think we
can hit it with cheese
we're gonna melt it all right so you're
just gonna brush it
with the flame he basically just made
kobe jack cheeks
basically but wait there it is
this is uh this is the chef's anthem it
really is
sauce on the bottom tomato okay patty
the half char half moon onion half moon
onion like that
bang like that in that it does look like
it looks like a krabby patty almost
no it really does look like a krabby
patty we have a bounty a cornucopia
of fried potatoes in front of us what do
you think goes with that guy right there
there's nothing wrong with regular
french fry i think it's fine nothing
wrong
i'm down with it but because i want to
be different maybe i would go for a
waffle
but then again plenty of people are
doing waffle but there's not enough
people doing a tot
tots and if you make a perfect tot i
don't think
it is beatable and it's enough of a
different experience that you can have
this classic burger that has some adult
qualities to it
but then bring back that ultra nostalgia
with the top agreed tots are great
so we have our burger we have our tots
now i think we need to make our drink
more specifically a paloma the simplest
way i could put a paloma is it's a
grapefruit forward tequila beverage does
that feel right does that look good
take your paloma all right that's gonna
go
into your glass that already has ice in
it okay you're gonna top it
yeah somebody did that
who did that that was christian did we
plan that
did we [ __ ] plan that top it off with
a little bit of uh
a little bit of this bubbly all right
and you're going to give it a good uh
that's a juicy one this is your perfect
burger meal right there we're playing it
safe
since i can't taste that burger channel
your inner alvin
all right folks this looks like a pretty
good burger
[Music]
[ __ ] just [ __ ] all this [ __ ] just
[ __ ] eat it
moment of truth time cross sections
it's a cross section right there look at
that
[Music]
normally i would do me cheese bun but
that is baller
the onions who caramelized these they're
[ __ ] perfect
oh my god and then the paloma
oh that's refreshing that's refreshing
it's gotta be this is insanely
refreshing
i [ __ ] want one my turn when i think
of perfect burger
i still go back to meet cheese and butt
the burger that really pushes through
that that i feel that i want to recreate
and what i thought was a perfect burger
meal
was from peter luger's in brooklyn right
so this is somewhat similar to that but
not exactly the same
so i'm starting off with this bun this
is my bun that i created with our baker
coated in sesame seed now this is just
chuck and then i'm going to make
my burger sauce oh it's already missed
out why wasn't mine
yeah i've become that guy i have pickled
serrano's twice as much of sweet pickled
relish
and then red onion that is my vegetable
for my burger
it's like a little pickle salad so yeah
my ideal burger and like this goes with
like
what i have at in and out it always has
a little bit of spice
i'm gonna make a little sauce with just
dijon mustard and mayo it's gonna have
that nice
astringent flavor of the dijon but it's
gonna contrast really well with the
spice
and the sweetness of the relish i'll
pre-patty this
so that it's about a half inch bigger
than the circumference of the bun
because you have to allow
for the shrinkage of of the meat throw
that in
at peter luger it's literally a really
thick dry age patty
raw onion and cheese yeah i bet you love
that
oh it's it's perfect and then i'm gonna
hit it with some fresh cracked pepper
it's smelling good just moving the oil
around
so that it hits the edges of the burger
that's an underrated technique
bam look at that look at that nice crust
on there
now i'm gonna top it with some cheese
this is american cheese oh no
look i like american cheese yeah this is
why you don't need the torch american
cheese is classic
i'm gonna put a little bit of this
mustard
mayo on here everything's so natural his
movements just
it's almost like they whisper burger i'm
hitting it with my relish
that looks beautiful plump boy oh yeah
yeah that looks fire i'm gonna top this
oh that's a
that's a pretty burger and that's it i
mean beautiful look at that
this is my go-to french fry for this
particular burger
it's just fun right it's a fun fry
and then a little bit of chipotle mayo
on the side i got the burger i got the
fries
now i'm gonna make you my drink it's
super simple
styrofoam cups double wall
double double cup love crushed
chewable ice matthew mcconaughey is
crying
and last but not least i have a soda
made by a pediatrician this is the
burger show perfect burger
meal and look look it's just like
perfect the layers is it's like
no and also soda nostalgia or lean i
don't know what that is
so yeah not the lean's not in there yet
yeah okay that's uh
that's later that's after we go that's
after we cut
look at the juices i'm gonna channel do
the b-roll dude my it my inner jade dubs
no it's mesa please don't say crispy
it's so done
oh yeah look at that it's beautiful the
cheese is melty
the bun is great now let's give it a
little taste
see now that right there that's better
than most burgers out there
because i made it let's try the fry
waffle fry love the waffle fry
into the chipotle plate out chipotle
mayo but it's all good
you hear that still
crispy
oh that's awful
soda can soda i'd rather make my own
soda
but it's pretty good so
[ __ ] i mean there's a lot of things that
we learned what did we learn
my god um buy your own ingredients don't
trust
any pressurized containers
in this room but also
you're uh you're like a burger marksman
burger king and you are
the composer the composer of glorious
food
and you didn't fall short today thanks
for coming on the show man
i appreciate it burger people watch his
show
watch my show burger love baby
burger love
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
watching the burger show make sure you
hit that like button
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that notification bell
if not for me for the burgers thank you